thistles big green deep cleaning machine
is quick and easy to use
start by vacuuming the entire area
remove the dirty water tank from the top
and lift the clean water tank from the
base of the machine take the clean water
tank to your sink now fill with hot tap
water to the waterline that's indicated
on the tank add two capfuls of Bissell
solution you've got plenty of solution
choices to fit your cleaning needs next
replace the tanks making sure the dirty
water tank is properly seated on top of
the clean water tank and you're ready to
clean start the Machine and recline the
handle press the trigger and make one
slow forward and backward pass over the
area release the trigger and make one
slow forward and backward pass over the
same area to suction up additional dirty
water from the carpet avoid over
saturating the area the flow indicator
on the machine stopped spinning
to let you know when you need more water
in solution empty the dirty water tank
into the sink and refill the clean water
tank with additional water and solution
as necessary when you are completely
finished cleaning make sure to empty and
rinse both the clean and dirty water
tanks and return back onto the machine
check the brushroll and the bottom of
the machine for dirt and debris quick
easy and you're done Bissell's big green
deep cleaning machine